report from our arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer contains
some flash photography from the start
lord andrew lloyd webber is perhaps a
surprising champion of women's rights
but there is a shared spirit if you like
between malala yousafzai and his new
show
cinderella
[Music]
in his fairy tale reboot cinderella is a
strong-willed young woman who won't
change to please others equality is an
issue the composer is passionate about
along with the refugee crisis i think of
balala she came here you know due to
circumstances that we all know about in
pakistan britain is a overcrowded
country in many ways and our various
social services are pretty overstretched
but at the same time they are not
overstretched when you consider the lot
of so many people and therefore i do
feel that we've got to find a way that a
country like britain and indeed all
western countries america which has
always been very tolerant of immigrants
i think we've got to find a way that we
can allow people who have genuinely been
displaced for various reasons
it's been a challenging 18 months for
lord lloyd webber who at one stage spoke
about selling his six west end theatres
if government restrictions weren't
relaxed even going so far as to say he
was willing to get arrested if this
production couldn't open over the summer
well i was completely serious about it i
mean i'm a composer i'm a you know i
write music and i want to get on and
write my next piece
but i found myself in a rather strange
situation where i seem to be speaking
for
the theater community and indeed live
music too and i suppose it was the
unfairness and the inconsistency of
everything that made me feel that you
know it had to speak out a bit
do you feel more supported now by the
government we know there's a new culture
minister nadine doris are you in touch
with her i'm waiting for her phone call
but she's been there for a while and i
ain't heard anything from her
currently moulin rouge is the only west
end show that requires you to agree to
wear a mask at booking and cabaret
demands lateral flow tests before entry
the theatre industry has a long way to
go to get over the catastrophic
financial impact it's endured for lord
lloyd webber the curtain is now finally
up and while he can he wants to support
those causes close to his heart katie
spencer sky news